Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof. Hello, Walter.
>> Why are you sitting in that chair?
>> I belong here.
>> Oh,
>> don't I?
>> As long as I don't get stuck.
Yeah.
>> I'm not going to ask you how you are.
>> Okay. I won't ask either.
>> Good. Let's just get on.
>> I'm very happy to hear that.
>> Everybody wants to know how you are.
>> Oh,
>> I know that.
>> As long as we're sitting here, we must
be okay.
>> We didn't have to record anything in a
hospital bed or so like in a sick bed.
So,
>> you spent a little time there. We seem
to take turns every now and then.
>> Yeah. every now and then, but at least
it wasn't anything serious. So, yeah,
we're carrying on.
>> All right, we're going to talk about
this invitation to a wedding. We haven't
recorded it as a WhatsApp prof yet, so
uh nice picture that we have in the
background here. Looks like a fancy
wedding. What do you say?
>> Yeah, definitely. I've not been invited
to a wedding like this before. The
weddings that I've been to is beautiful,
but this looks quite extravagant.
>> This looks uh something that Donald
Trump might have in mind.
>> His ballroom that
>> his ballroom that nobody wants.
Anyway, there's lots that we could talk
about the events in the world, but I
think we will we will shelf that until
there is more clarity. Mhm. M
>> you know, we could become a a news
broadcaster and give a running
commentary,
>> but uh the thing is not resolved yet.
And once it is resolved, we'll know
where it's going.
>> And our eye is on the 4th of July and on
the things that'll be happening on the
17th of this month. And so we'll talk
about those things when they actually
happen.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Let's open with a word of prayer. That's
perhaps a good idea. Very good idea.
>> Go into this. Our heavenly father, thank
you once again that we can be here.
Thank you that you've protected and
guided us thus far and we ask that you
also do the same through this discussion
and help us in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
I think this one is incredibly important
so that we can understand
that it is not conjecture when we say
that uh we are living in the time of the
final events
and all of these things had to take
place
and it's very interesting to see how
accurate the Bible is and how
meticulously and carefully you must read
it. So this is this is actually for
everyone to understand
that God is consistent, that God is
fair,
>> and that uh he has done everything
possible
to inform people as to the times we are
living in
>> and it's not his fault if they
collectively reject it.
>> Yeah, it's a choice.
>> It's a choice. So let's have a look at
an invitation to a wedding.
Give us a king. 1st Samuel 8:6.
But the thing displeased Samuel. The
fact that they wanted a king, right?
>> Of course.
>> When they said, "Give us a king to judge
us." And Samuel prayed unto the Lord.
And the Lord said unto Samuel, "Hearken
unto the voice of the people in all that
they say unto thee, for they have not
rejected thee, but they have rejected me
that I should not reign over them."
The The interesting thing is, Martin,
they were always willing to have him as
God.
>> Yes. But not
>> but not as ruler.
>> Not as ruler. They Yeah. Thank you.
We want certain things that you provide,
but when it comes to adhere to what you
want, no.
>> Exactly. Thank you for the daily bread.
Thank you for the rain. Thank you for
that. But hello, we we've got this
thing, right?
>> Yeah.
>> This is humanity.
>> Exactly the same today.
>> And nothing's going to change. So the
real thing is, do you want him as Lord
and Savior? Most people will say yes.
Mhm.
>> Do you want him as your ruler?
>> No.
>> Do you want him as your king? Sometimes
they'll say yes. But when they say yes,
it's because then they believe they're
empowered
to do the ruling on his behalf.
>> Yes. To do it on his behalf. As long as
he stays in heaven, that's great.
Don't come and mess with us down here.
Ezekiel 21 26. Thus says the Lord God,
remove the diadem.
So there comes a point where this thing
with the king didn't really work out.
And God says, "Remove that diadem, that
crown. Get rid of it. And take off the
crown. This shall not be the same. Exalt
him that is low and abase him that is
high. I will overturn
overturn
overturn it and it shall be no more
until he come whose right it is and I
will give it to him.
>> So this is talking about the crown
belongs to Jesus Christ.
>> Yeah,
>> he is the king
>> and the Lord permitted these earthly
governments and this earthly kingship.
But there are three overturns there. Now
you can you can interpret that in
various ways. I think uh maybe even
double applications
>> because there was an overturning
when Israel
>> was taken into captivity. That was the
crown that was gone.
>> And then there was an overturning when
Judah went into captivity.
>> Right?
And then there is another overturning
over here. So
this is something that will happen maybe
at the end of time.
>> It could be. Let's
>> do you think maybe there was also was it
an overturn when Jesus said that your
house has left you desolate?
>> Sure. But that that is not taking away
the kingship because it was gone
already.
>> Oh yeah. True. Yeah. Yeah.
>> It was gone already. There's another
possibility if we look at it in terms of
the end time. There is an overturning
for Israel.
>> Get rid of the kingships in Israel.
Then there was the papacy that claimed
the crown.
>> Yeah.
>> And said, "Okay, I'm going to put the
diadem on my head. We've got this. All
right, King Jesus. We we don't really
want you." And if you think of all of
those wars, you know, and the wars
between even the Protestant
in England with the king as the head of
the church
>> and the Scots saying we have no king but
Jesus and those wars that took place
over there as to who's the king.
>> And uh so this contention as to who is
the king has been ongoing.
So there was an overturning for Israel.
>> Mhm. There was an overturning when the
diadem was taken off the secular
rulership of the papacy 1798 the mortal
wound
>> and there will be a final overturning
just before Jesus comes because he is
the one who gets the crown
>> and it's an overturning of the kingship.
>> It's the kings of the earth are going.
>> Yeah.
>> The real king is going to rule. I'm just
thinking about the king that went to
visit
um well King Trump.
>> Yes,
>> that was a spectacle actually.
>> It was a very interesting spectacle
>> and we'll we we have to show something
of that.
>> We'll do one when the time comes. We'll
do one on that. So it shall be no more
there will be no more kings, earthly
kings, no earthly rulers and it will be
given to the one whom it really belongs
to. That's Jesus Christ. So it's not
good enough to accept him as your Lord
and Redeemer.
>> You have to accept his government.
>> Yeah.
>> Is government based on law?
>> Yes.
>> Don't they always talk about the rule of
law?
>> The whole time.
>> The whole time. Right.
>> And they've got hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of laws and they want that.
>> Yeah.
>> But God's got 10.
>> Get away. 10. Take it away.
>> Give us give usund hundreds and most of
them uh totally against your
humanity.
>> Exactly.
>> All right. So there will be an
overturning. Whichever way we look at
it, it is fascinating to me.
Genesis 49:10. The scepter shall not
depart from Judah, nor lawgiver from
between his feet until Sheilo come.
Now Jesus came already, didn't he?
>> Yeah.
>> So the Messiah has come. So
theoretically if you become a Christian
and you accept him, don't you accept him
as your king as well?
>> You have to both savior, king.
>> King Okay.
And unto him shall be the gathering of
the people. So Martin when it comes to
salvation and obedience
we have to submit in terms of both of
them.
>> Matthew 2:es 1 and two. Now when Jesus
was born in Bethlehem of Judea in the
days of Herod the king, behold there
came wise men from the east to Jerusalem
saying where is he that is born king of
the Jews? This freaked them out. Yeah,
of course.
Especially when you come to the
>> what's this king business? I'm the king
around here.
>> For we have seen his star in the east
and have come to worship him. So there
are two aspects here.
>> There is the worship and there's the
acceptance of a ruler over your life.
Not very popular amongst humanity. Not
at all.
Now
listen to this conversation. I find this
very interesting.
This is in John.
Jesus calls Philillip
and then Philip goes and calls
Nathaniel. Right?
And the day following Jesus would go
forth from Galilee and findeth Philillip
and says unto him, follow me.
Now Philip was of Betsa, the city of
Andrew and Peter. Phillip findeth
Nathaniel,
and says unto him, we have found him of
whom Moses and the law and the prophets
did right, Jesus of Nazareth, the son of
Joseph.
So he's telling him, "We found the
Messiah."
>> Yeah. But uh also interesting, typical
Phillip,
he's a little bit on the safe side. He
doesn't want to say, "We find the
Messiah.
You say we found Jesus uh of Nazareth,
the son of Joseph. It's he's not going
completely the not going all the way.
And Nathaniel said to him, "Can there
any good thing come out of Nazareth?"
Philip says unto him, "Come and see."
So, let's just talk about that for a
while. I'm sure Nathaniel heard John the
Baptist say, "Behold the lamb of God."
>> And so, he was sitting under the tree
thinking, "Is that possible?
uh studying the prophecies. Does this
Messiah really come out of a place like
Nazareth? Yeah.
>> And can this be the one? Has uh has John
the Baptist lost his marbles or
is this the truth? Don't you think
that's what he was thinking about?
>> Of course. Yeah. It's
>> all right. And now Philip says to him,
"We have found him." The one that Moses
wrote about. He doesn't say the one that
John the Baptist said.
>> No.
>> No. The one that Moses said.
And he said, "I, you know, I'm not sure
about this thing." And then the only
answer that he gets is, "Come and see."
>> Wow.
>> Jesus saw Nathaniel coming to him and
said unto him, "Behold, an Israel indeed
in in whom is no guile."
Nathaniel said unto him, "When th now
thou me?" He never met him or anything
like that.
And Jesus answered and said unto him,
"Before that Philillip called thee, when
there was under the fig tree, I saw
thee." That's all he needed.
>> You know, but it makes sense of how you
just explained earlier. He was sitting
contemplating.
>> Yeah. Is this the one?
>> Yeah. And
>> and now he says, "Okay, this one is
different because he couldn't have known
that."
>> It's almost as Jesus shows to him. He
could read his mind.
>> Right. Philip couldn't have informed him
because this happened before Philip
found him.
>> He was no longer sitting under the tree,
right? Contemplating these things.
>> But look at his look at his response.
>> Nathaniel answered and said unto him,
"Rabbi," that's teacher, "Thou art the
son of God." That's amazing.
>> Finished. He believed it.
>> But then he adds, "Thou art the king of
Israel."
>> of Israel.
>> So he accepts both.
>> Both. Yeah.
>> Right. He accepts both.
>> Is that's what we must do?
>> 100% the same.
>> Okay. Will the rest of the world do it?
No. Did Herod do it? No.
>> Did the Pharisees do it? Let's just make
sure they they're all happy
>> with a Messiah that is your, you know,
fairy godmother
>> and is going to help you out of all your
troubles and strife. But, uh, you know,
the rulership, leave that to me.
Zechariah also says, "Rejoice greatly, O
daughter of Zion. Shout, O daughter of
Jerusalem. Behold, thy king cometh unto
thee.
He is just and having salvation, lowly
and riding upon an ass, and upon the
cult, the fo of an ass." So the diadem
went to him. When did it go to him?
>> Right there. Yeah.
>> Right at the triumphant entry. Yeah.
>> He took the diadem. He acknowledged he
received the acknowledgment as not only
the Messiah,
>> but as king.
>> As king.
>> That freaked the others out, right?
Tell those disciples to shut up.
That's what they said.
>> Can't you just make them shut up?
saying unto them, Matthew 21, to go into
the village over against you,
straightway you shall find an ass tied
and a cult with her. Loose them, and
bring them unto me. And if any man say
unto you, you shall say, The Lord has
need of them,
>> and straightway we will send them. All
this was done that it might be fulfilled
what was spoken by the prophet, saying,
Tell ye the daughter of Zion, behold thy
>> king cometh unto thee meek and sitting
upon an ass and a cult the fo of an ass.
So there is this quote from Zechariah.
Martin, we're dealing with the kingship.
>> Kingship has rulership.
Rulership has a rule of law.
>> Yeah.
So what they actually gave him a mock
coronation, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Then the soldiers of the governor took
Jesus into the common hall and gathered
unto him the whole band of soldiers.
They stripped him and put on him a
scarlet robe.
So that must be an old robe that was
once worn by a king. M
>> and when they had plattered the crown of
thorns, they put it upon his head and a
reed in his hand, and they bowed the
knee before him
>> and mocked him, saying, "Hail, King of
the Jews."
>> But this is just after the triumphant
entry.
This is one week, in fact.
>> One week.
>> Actually, it's not even a full week. No,
>> no, no.
>> It's the sixth day.
>> Mhm.
and they spit upon him and took the reed
and smote him on the head.
What does verse 11 of chapter 27 say?
Jesus stood before the governor and the
governor asked him, "At thou the king of
the Jews." He didn't ask him, "Are you
the Messiah?"
>> No,
didn't ask him that. It wasn't a
religious question.
It are you the king?
>> Because this is where the rivalry comes
in with another king. Whether it be
Caesar in the case of the governor,
>> he was scared of Caesar. That's why he
acted upon what the Jews said.
>> Mhm.
>> Or is it something else?
>> Or even Herod, you know, anyone that was
in the position of king? This this was a
>> this was a problem.
>> And Jesus stood before the governor, and
the governor asked him saying, "Art thou
the king of the Jews?" And Jesus said
unto him, "Thou sayest, you said it."
Yeah, you said it.
>> Did he deny it?
>> No.
>> No. So, he must have received it.
>> Yep.
>> John 18:39. But ye have a custom that I
should release unto you one of the at
the Passover. Will you therefore that I
release to you
>> your Messiah? No, it doesn't say that.
>> King of the Jews.
>> The King of the Jews.
Matthew 27:37 says, "And set up over his
head his accusation."
This is Jesus, the king of the Jews. So
what was the accusation? That he was the
king.
>> Yeah.
>> That he was the king.
Martin, this is this is fascinating. So
this is human nature.
Don't want to be ruled over.
In fact, well,
>> we don't even want to be ruled over by
the earthly kings.
>> No,
>> cuz that's they make such a mess of it.
>> But it's weird. People don't want to be
ruled over them.
>> But then every now and then you see they
take a dictator over them again. They
they want then they want it again.
>> They want and when that king goes by,
they all wave their little flags.
I would protest. I wouldn't wear the I
wouldn't wave the little flag because
that king definitely doesn't represent
me.
>> He doesn't because let's say King
Charles.
He says he wants to be defender of
faith.
>> He wants to be more of a Muslim than he
wants to be a Christian. And in fact,
the Christians were all up in arms
because he was more concerned with
Ramadan than he was with Easter. Right.
>> So fascinating. And he's got these these
environmentalist ideas which I think are
a load of hogwash.
And why should I wave my little flag at
him just because he's got a silly crown
on his head? Right.
>> But this king is different.
>> Yeah. No, this one. This one is
different.
>> I will definitely wave the flag. Now,
>> now Martin, you would only want to have
this king
over you if this king's
thinking
is in harmony with you,
>> right?
>> Of course. Definitely.
>> If you look at all the legends of King
Arthur,
>> Mhm.
>> he was such a benevolent man. Everybody
bowed down. Everybody wanted his
rulership. Nobody wants this one's
rulership. Why not?
>> I I don't know. Do they do they see him
as a weakling?
>> I don't know. Just because he is kind,
but he's he's not pushover, right?
>> No, no, no,
>> no. He is the the captain of the king's
of the of the Lord's host.
>> Yeah.
>> John 19:15. But they cried, "Away with
him! Away with him! Crucify him!
Pilate said unto them, "Shall I crucify
your king?" He's really rubbing it in.
The chief priests answered, "We have no
king but Caesar." That is a very
lamentable statement.
>> No, no. Can you imagine
the chosen people of God
throws him away as king and chooses
Caesar? So when you accept him as king,
you are accepting another form of
government. You are accepting rulership.
So let's make quite sure that this is
the situation. And why did they reject
him? John 11:49. And one of them named
Caiaphas
being the high priest that same year
said unto them, "Ye know nothing at all,
nor consider that it is expedient for us
that one man should die for the people
and that the whole nation perish not."
They realized that their their system of
governance
would be gone.
They know would no longer qualify as
that kingly power
cuz the other one would be king now.
>> Yeah.
>> And they would have to be subservient.
>> Yes.
>> Yep.
>> No, no, no. We We want a sugar daddy.
We don't want a king. We are in control
of ourselves
>> because we love our position. And this
spake he not of himself, but being high
priest that year, he prophesied that
Jesus would die for that nation. And not
for that nation only, but that also he
should gather together in one the
children of God that were scattered
abroad.
>> Now,
the talk that we're having today is
about an invitation
to what?
>> To a wedding.
>> Wedding
>> of the king.
>> Yeah. Wow.
>> Being aligned, married as it were, in a
very close union to the king. And a
marriage is supposed to be a a covenant
for as long as you live.
>> Yeah.
>> That means, Martin, that there is no
escape from that covenant
>> if you take it as it should be. Right.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay.
John 11:49. And one of them named
Caiaphas being high priest that same
year said, "Ye know nothing at all."
What did he know?
>> He saw through the picture.
>> Yeah. He saw that the all his rulership,
all of their like you just mentioned
their
>> hierarchy, everything gone.
>> It will be gone. His position will be
>> worth nothing.
>> He's the high priest.
>> And here is the and the typical high
priest standing in front of him.
>> No,
>> I don't want this. Get out of here.
>> Get rid of him. He, in other words, he
understood it.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> He understood the consequences.
1 Timothy 6:13 I give thee charge in the
sight of God who quickenth all things
and before Christ Jesus who before
Pontius Pilate witnessed a good
confession
that thou keep this commandment without
spot unrebukeable until the appearing of
our Lord Jesus Christ which in his time
he shall show who is the blessed and
potentate the king of kings and lord of
lords. So, Martin, how long must we be
subject to this new king?
>> Forever.
But why don't we see it right now? Why?
Because in his time, he will reveal it.
>> But by faith, you should already grab
it.
>> When in his time, he shall show. Who is
the blessed and only potent
the king of kings and lord of lords?
That's his double title. That's his
ruler and his redeemer.
>> Yeah.
>> Who only has immortality and therefore
is the only one who can give you eternal
life. Conditional.
>> Dwelling in the light which no man can
approach. Unto whom no man has seen nor
can see. to whom be honor and power
everlasting. Amen.
So this power is going to take over the
kingship like it or not. Overturn,
overturn and a final overturn.
So can we say that the religious leaders
were there to guide in spiritual
matters? The king was there to rule in
temporal matters.
Yeah.
>> But in the Messiah, you have them
>> both.
>> Both.
>> Yeah.
>> Accepting a king is accepting the
government,
the laws, the statutes, and submitting
to his authority.
>> Mhm.
>> That means that your authority is gone.
You've relinquished it and given it to
him.
>> Tough tough call.
>> That's exactly why the world is
struggling.
>> Are there people in the world that
refuse to give up their power?
Many
>> most right
>> most
>> okay
>> that's for sure I can think of quite a
few current leaders of countries
>> that won't give up their power
>> even if they've been bombed to
smitherines they still won't give it up
right
in Matthew Matthew chapter 15 the
conflict of authority is addressed the
consequences of choosing one's own
authority over that of God is also
addressed
So firstly, there's a conflict between
tradition and the commandments of God
or the conflict between a thus sayeth
the Lord and a thus saith man. That's a
conflict.
>> Yeah.
Secondly, the effect of tradition on the
transformation of the heart is addressed
as tradition silences the conscience and
replaces the voice of the Holy Spirit
with rituals
that lull humanity and a false sense of
security. Could you agree with that?
>> 100%. Especially if I think about the
Catholic Church where the liturgy
is more important than actual word.
>> Correct. Correct. And thirdly, once
tradition has placed replaced obedience
and adherence to a thus says the lord,
then the condition becomes hopeless and
spiritual blindness follows which is
incurable.
>> That is what ignitian spirituality does
to you.
>> Yeah.
>> It replaces faith
with uh paraphernalia.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And emotions.
>> And emotions.
And then eventually you get to the point
where you say, "Leave them alone." Or
how did how did the Lord say it? Ephraim
is joined to idols. Let him go.
>> So it waxes worse and worse and
eventually loses all discernment and
becomes a house of demons.
That's where the Jews were. They had so
ritualized the religion and made that a
redemptive quality
>> that there was no hope left for them.
The whole system must be swept away.
Then came to Jesus scribes and Pharisees
which were of Jerusalem saying, Why do
thy disciples transgress the traditions
of the elders?
For they wash not their hands when they
eat bread. Are we having two sets of
regulations and laws in juiposition
here?
>> Yeah. You got the tradition of the
elders and the laws of God.
>> The one is the form. The other one
addresses the heart. Right.
>> Exactly. Why do you have to worship?
Because you have to purify.
>> But he answered and said unto them, why
do you also transgress the commandments
of God by your tradition?
>> It's pretty sharp answer.
For God commanded, saying, "Honor thy
father and mother, and he that cirth
father and mother, let him die the
death. But ye say, whoever shall say to
his father is his mother, it is a gift.
By whatever thou mayast be profited by
me, and honor not the his father or
mother, he shall be free."
So they were saying, okay, you should
really in their old age take care of
your parents. Remember, there were no
old age homes in those days. The state
didn't give you a state pension to take
care of you.
So this fell upon the upon the children.
Yeah.
>> But uh if you gave that money with which
you were going to do it to the temple,
in other words to the Pharisees, then
you were freed of your obligation which
is breaking the commandments of God.
>> Of course. Martin Martin Luther
>> when he went into the monastery was he
also freed from his obligation to take
care of his parents because he was now
joined to the church
>> and serving them.
>> No.
>> Yes.
>> Well, he was then. Yeah. Because he
couldn't do it.
>> Exactly the same thing. The Catholic
Church did exactly the same thing did.
>> Exactly the same thing.
>> Well, they still do it today. And so
it says quite plainly, thus have you
made the commandments of God of none
effect by your tradition. And he
basically tells them, you hypocrites.
Well, did Isaiah prophesy of you,
saying, "The people draw nigh to me with
their mouth and honoring me with their
lips, but their hearts are far from me."
They want a Messiah, but they don't want
a king. King. Yeah.
>> They want a Messiah, but they don't want
a king.
And Jesus s said, "Are you also without
understanding?" Speaking to the
disciples, "Do you not yet understand
that whatsoever enterth into the mouth
goes into the belly and is cast out into
the draft? Is he talking about food now?
Is he talking about traditions?" The
problem is that most modern translations
use this and explanations that this is
talking about food.
In other words, they are really ignorant
of what the issue is.
>> I think if I'm not mistaken, in some
Bibles, it even has in brackets here,
therefore Jesus declared all foods
clean.
>> And Ivy,
absolute travesty of justice.
But those things which proceed out of
the mouth come from the heart and they
defile a man.
So is this issue about food or is it
about spirituality? uality.
For out of the heart proceeds evil
thoughts, murders, adulteries,
fornication, theft, false witness,
blasphemies. Is that all in the ten
commandments?
>> Yep.
>> Isn't murder?
>> Yeah. So,
>> adultery,
theft, false witness, lying, blasphemy.
Isn't that ten commandments?
>> Ten Commandments. And that's to show
you, listen, this is not about food.
This has got about character. All the
things you're doing. So these are the
things which defile a man.
>> But to eat with unwashed hands defileth
not a man.
>> And it's interesting that from that
confrontation
Jesus immediately goes to a Canaanite
woman.
>> Yeah. To show because what that was also
um considered defilement.
>> All right. So that was considered a
defilement by them. But he was actually
saying, you know, your house is is
desolate.
>> Exactly.
>> Ephraim, you are joined to idols. I'm
going to let you go.
And Jesus went then and departed into
the coast of Ty and Sidon. And behold,
the woman of Canaan came out of the same
coasts and cried unto him, saying, Have
mercy on me, oh Lord, thou son of David.
What? Just think about son of David. M
>> was David the king.
>> Yeah.
>> So, does this make him an heir of the
rulership?
>> Exactly. 100%. Yeah.
>> The Jews didn't want a king. Here's a
Canaanite woman. A woman actually stands
symbolically for the church.
>> Yeah.
>> They're saying, "Okay, we accept you as
king, son of David." Wow.
>> My daughter is grievously vexed with the
devil. Imagine this. A Canaanite woman,
the worst of the worst, had more
discernment than the Israelites.
Very
an object lesson for the disciples. They
had only crumbs from the master's table
due to their neglect
were to be fed by the master of masters.
He himself came.
>> All right, Martin, let's jump from there
to the end time conspiracy. We haven't
come to the wedding yet. We're building
up to the wedding. Relax. We we will get
to the wedding.
>> Revelation 17:11,
there's a beast
that was and is not even he the eighth
and of the seven and goes into pition.
We've dealt with that prophetically over
a number of times.
And then there are 10 horns
which thou sour 10 kings which have not
received the kingdom of yet but receive
power as kings one hour with the beast.
So that's when the spiritual sword of
the Catholic Church will again rule over
the secular sword of the kings.
>> So we're on our way to this.
>> We're on our way.
>> They have one mind.
You know, even Herod and Pilate and the
Pharisees, the Herodians and the
Pharisees, they were all one in their
condemnation in the end.
>> And they will give their strength unto
the beast.
>> And these shall make war with the Lamb.
So we have the same situation.
But the Lamb shall overcome them. He is
Lord of Lords and King of Kings. And
they that are with him are called and
chosen and faithful.
faithful to the king.
>> Yeah.
>> And he has on his vest on his thigh name
written king of kings,
lord of lords. So we have to accept this
rulership.
But no, they want a temporal millennium
where they rule
>> or even a millennium where they rule
forever.
>> Correct?
So when Christ came to his this earth,
he set up a kingdom that was not from
this world, but the kingdom came nigh to
us, so that all who were willing could
press into it,
and into whatsoever city ye enter. Luke
10:8,
and they receive you, eat such things as
thou set before you. Heal the sick that
are therein, say unto them, the kingdom
of God has come nigh unto you. There is
a king. For the kingdom of heaven is
like unto a man that is a householder
which went out early in the morning to
hire laborers into his vineyard. Now
notice Martin modern, this is early in
the morning.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> So this is the beginning of the
Messiah's reign.
>> Uhhuh. We will have an evening at some
stage when it is the end of this period
before Christ comes to take up the
literal kingship.
So this is early in the morning.
So the Messiah is here and he's talking
to the Jews.
The law and the prophets were until
John, John the Baptist.
Since that time the kingdom of God is
preached.
>> So when did the kingdom start?
>> When John the Baptist preached and said
>> correct
>> remove the diadem and I will give it to
him to whom it belongs to Sheilum to the
Messiah.
>> Okay.
And since that time every man presses
into it.
>> Yeah.
>> So you can become part of this kingdom
by faith.
>> Yes. And by accepting the rules. Ex.
>> Exactly.
Accepting the plan of salvation and
subjecting yourself to the government.
>> Yeah.
>> It is easier for heaven and earth to
pass away than one tit of the law to
fail.
So not one tit of the law is going to
fail. This is going to be accomplished.
>> Mhm.
>> And the ten commandments are part of the
law.
>> That's it. that the law and the of the
kingdom stands.
>> So what happened when they started
preaching this? The disciples were
persecuted
>> for his name's sake. So can the same
happen again?
>> It's a promise it will.
>> So when they had brought them, they set
them before the council. And the high
priest asked them, saying, "Did not we
straightly command you that you should
not teach in this name? and behold, you
have filled Jerusalem with your doctrine
and intend to bring this man's blood
upon us. Why had they rejected him?
Because he's a king.
>> He didn't want a king, right?
>> And Peter and the apostles answered and
said, "We ought to obey God rather than
man. The God of our fathers raised up
Jesus whom ye slew and hanged on a tree.
Him has God exalted with the right hand
with his right hand to be prince
and savior for to give repentance to
Israel and forgiveness of sins. So we
both have the ruler and the salvation
there again.
And so we are his witnesses of these
things and so also is the Holy Ghost
whom God has given to them that
>> obey you stick to the rules. So you've
got a king.
>> Yeah.
>> And when they heard this, they were cut
to the heart and to counsel to slay
them.
>> Don't preach this this kind of stuff.
>> We've got our own rules.
>> Yeah.
I'm just It just runs sometimes. We've
also heard many times, you're not you're
not going to say this and this and this.
To who are you going to listen?
>> Exactly. Who are you going to listen to?
>> To the king or to them? So let's make
sure the rulers and the kings were
arrayed against him.
Acts 4:26, the kings of the earth stood
up. The rulers were gathered together
against the Lord and against his Christ.
For of a truth against thy holy child
Jesus, whom thou has anointed, both
Herod
and Pilate
with the Gentiles
and the people of Israel were gathered
together. All of them. Wow. So Martin,
in the end, can we expect the rulers of
the world, those that are not Christian
and even those that call themselves
Christian
>> be arrayed against them?
>> Definitely.
>> About what? About kingship, right?
Coming to rule.
>> Yeah. Wow.
>> As it was, sin will, so will it be. Now,
Revelation 19, and I saw the beast,
>> who had received all this power and
accolades, and the kings of the earth,
and their armies gathered together to
make war against them that sat on the
horse, and against his armies. The same
thing going to happen at the end. So,
repetitive repetition.
>> Absolutely.
So now we're finally ready for the
wedding. We've seen that that what
happened then a universal rejection
except those that were pressing into
that kingdom.
>> Yes.
>> We will have a universal rejecting
except those that accept the invitation.
>> Yeah.
>> Wow.
>> There were two wedding invitations.
You know, people confuse them and think
it's a repetition of the same story.
It's not.
So in Revelation we have a dinner.
>> Mhm.
>> Versing a supper.
>> So which one do we have in Revelation?
We have a supper in Revelation. But
early on we had a dinner. So let's just
have a look at that. Revelation 19. This
is the end.
>> Uhhuh.
>> And he said unto me, write blessed are
they which are called unto the marriage
>> supper.
>> Supper
>> of the lamb. So that's at the end of the
Christian dispensation revelation. Yeah.
>> And he said unto me, "These are the true
sayings of God." So when the Jews
rejected the Messiah,
>> the call to worship him went to the
Gentiles. Right.
>> Mhm.
>> It was fitting that the first invitation
should go to the Jews.
>> Yeah. Go ye first to the lost children
of Israel.
Who were the people chosen by God to
represent him at the time?
John 4:22, "Ye worship, ye know not what
we know what we worship, for salvation
is of the Jews."
>> So the Jews were God's people to present
to the world
the Messiah.
>> Yeah.
>> The coming redeemer,
>> the king.
>> Yeah. They rejected
>> God as king. They wanted an earthly
king.
>> They did all the other things. Okay.
>> Yes.
>> You know, doing the ritual, he will be
slaughtering the lamb, all this other
stuff. But when it came to the portion
where he's going to be the king,
>> no, not interested. All right. Matthew
10:5. These 12 Jesus sent forth and
commanded them, saying, "Go not into the
way of the Gentiles,
and into any city of the Samaritans,
enter ye not." Although Jesus had just
been
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> to some of these,
>> but go gather to the lost sheep of the
house of Israel.
>> That's your focus for
>> That's your focus. And as you go, preach
saying, "The kingdom of heaven is at
hand." Mhm.
>> How long was that to be until the end of
the 70 prophecy
>> to the stoning of Steven?
>> Yeah. So this three and a half years
after Jesus
>> then the time of probation for the Jews
as a nation was over
>> right
>> just as it had come to the northern
tribes when the Assyrians took over and
said it's over. M
>> so when that time came and Steven was
stoned, Paul and Barnabas waxed bold and
said it was necessary
that the word of God should first have
been spoken to you to the Jews.
>> But seeing you put it from you and judge
yourself unworthy of everlasting life,
lo, we turn to the Gentiles. So that's
when the gospel went to the Gentiles and
the Jewish dispensation
ended
>> as a nation, not as individuals because
>> they came out.
>> Yeah. And they can press in to the
kingdom.
>> Correct. They were also came out in
droves during Pentecost.
So let's have a look at the first
wedding invitation. And this invitation
goes to the Jews.
>> Mhm. And it's important that people
understand this because if you get less
confused then you think okay but the
Jews still have a thing a role to play.
>> Yeah. They don't have a role to play.
What we have now is a Masonic construct
that's got nothing to do with the Bible.
It's a fake.
>> Yeah. Is it?
>> So the call to the Jews to accept the
Messiah as bridegroom and as king
is in the Bible called the dinner call.
Not a supper corn.
Let's read it. Matthew 22.
The kingdom of heaven is like unto a
certain king. Yeah. Which made a
marriage for his son and sent forth his
servants to call them that were bidden
to the wedding and they would not come.
Who's he talking about? He's talking
about the Jewish.
>> The Jews. Yeah. Now the king sent his
son for the wedding. invited. No.
>> Again he sent forth other servants,
saying, "Tell them which are bidden,
behold, I've prepared my dinner.
>> My oxen and my fatlings are killed, and
all things are ready. Come unto the
marriage."
So the table was set, right?
>> Yeah.
>> But they made light of it and went their
way, one to his farm, another to his
merchandise. And the remnant took his
servants and treated them spitefully and
slew them.
>> Now, what does this word dinner mean?
Well, let's go to the concordances and
have a look. It's the first food taken
early in the morning.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, the fact that terminology has
changed is irrelevant. You have to look
what does it mean in the Bible.
>> Yeah.
>> What's it in the original?
>> So, that's breakfast.
This is the first meal of the day. So
Jesus at his first coming
first invited the Jews. It was fitting
that the call should go to you first.
>> Of course
>> cuz you were supposed to be the
representatives.
>> So a later usage is dinner
>> dinner in the evening
>> which you don't know where where it is
now.
>> All right. So that was the first call,
the breakfast early in the morning.
But when the king heard thereof, he was
wroth and he sent forth his armies and
destroyed those murderers and burnt up
their city.
Did God use the Roman army to do that
for him?
>> 70 AD destruction of Jerusalem.
>> All right. Then said it to his servants,
"The wedding is ready, but they which
were bidden were not worthy."
>> It was necessary, said Paul, that it be
preached to you first.
>> But seeing that you count yourself
unworthy
of salvation, we turn to the Gentiles.
>> So now the Christian church turns to the
Gentiles.
Go ye therefore into the highways and as
many as you shall find bid to the
marriage. Now the highways stretched
from the city
>> to other places.
>> Yeah. It's outside.
>> Let's go away from Jerusalem, away from
the Jews. Let's go and gather the
others. So the servants went out into
the highways and ga gathered together
all as many as they found, both bad and
good. And the wedding was furnished with
guests.
And when the king came in to see the
guests, he saw there a man which had not
on a wedding garment. So in other words,
you had to accept Christ and his
righteousness
>> in order to be part of this.
>> Yeah.
>> But you also had to accept him as king.
>> So that's a righteous garment.
>> Correct. The role of righteousness.
He said unto him, "Friend, how camest
thou in he not having a wedding
garment?" And he was speechless. You had
to accept the righteousness of Christ.
>> So he came there
>> in his own righteousness.
>> In his own righteousness, works doing
good maybe.
>> And then said the king to his servants,
"Bind him hand and foot and take him
away and cast him into outer darkness.
There shall be weeping and nashing of
teeth. For many are called, but few are
chosen." All right. So here the wedding
invitation goes to the Gentiles
and the church now consisted of those
Jews that had heeded the call and the
new Gentiles and it became the Christian
church.
>> Yeah.
>> Now the Christian church is going to
continue for almost 2,000 years.
All right. At the end of that, shouldn't
there be a wedding invitation to accept
the coming king?
>> Yeah.
So can we say that the king sent his
armies the Romans to destroy their city
Jerusalem? Yep. That's what happened,
right? So the Jews had been the
custodians of the oracles of God.
>> They were the ones who were to preach
the coming of the Messiah, the king of
the Jews, but they failed miserably
because they wanted to set up an earthly
kingdom where they would be in control.
and they misapplied the prophecies and
the types and shadows and neglected the
substance. Would you agree with that
statement?
>> That's 100% what happened. That's why it
was left desolate to them.
>> Okay.
>> And and Jerusalem was destroyed.
>> And that is why Ka first could say it is
expedient that this man should die
rather than we give up our rulership.
>> Well, they tried it and then in
eventually in any case they lost even
more.
>> They lost even more. But that is human
nature.
So Romans 9:24, even us whom he has
called not of the Jews only, but also of
the Gentiles. So the church now
consisted of converted Jews
and Gentiles.
For by one spirit we are all baptized
into one body, whether we be Jews or
Gentiles, whether we be bond or free,
and have been all made to drink into one
spirit. So this wedding invitation was a
dinner invitation and that is breakfast
according to the concordance
>> to the Jews to accept Jesus as Messiah
which means anointed one the king of the
Jews
>> to accept his righteousness by faith his
atonement as the lamb of God that takes
away of the sins they had to accept the
wedding garment
>> they refused it Yeah, they don't even
have to buy it or anything. They just
had to accept it.
>> Correct. So, the gospel went to the
Gentiles and the Christian church
consisting of both Jews and Gentiles
constituted the spiritual Israel of God
that would henceforth preach the good
news to the world for the next almost
2,000 years. Would the Christian
churches, my question to you, Martin,
and to everybody out there, fare any
better than the Jews did in their long
history? Or would they emulate them and
aim to set up a kingdom for themselves?
Or would they pin their hopes on the
coming king and patiently hope for the
blessed hope?
>> Unfortunately, no.
>> No, they won't go that route, right?
They'll go the same route.
>> Yeah, exactly. We've seen that now
because the beast and everybody is going
to follow that route. Right?
>> So Martin at some stage there must come
a second invitation.
>> All right, let's look at the second
invitation. It's recorded in Luke
>> and it's also an invitation to a wedding
banquet, but it's a supper invitation.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So this is at the end of the Christian
dispensation.
Revelation 19:19.
And he said unto me, write blessed are
they which are called unto the marriage
supper of the lamb. It's not the same
meal.
>> No,
>> one was a breakfast.
>> And he said unto me, these are the true
sayings of God. So the supper is the
last meal of the day, not to be confused
with the dinner,
breakfast of Matthew. This supper is the
same as the first angel's call to the
churches.
It went to to the bidden
to the churches that accepted Christ. So
just like it was necessary for us to
preach to you first
>> because you were supposed to be the
representatives,
>> the last message goes to the church. It
was necessary that we're going to preach
it to you. The king is coming.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you want him?
>> No.
We want to rule
first and they rejected it just like the
Jews rejected the call to the dinner.
Let's make sure of this Martin.
>> Luke 14:16-24.
Then said he unto him, a certain man
made a great supper. It's not the same
meal.
>> No, it's not. Yeah. So, it's not the
same occasion.
>> No. And bade many.
>> Yeah.
Let's make sure the word is a different
Greek word. It's dipon which means
supper held at the evening
beginning of the ministry or the
beginning of the Christian dispensation.
The end of the Christian dispensation
used of the Messiah's feast symbolizing
salvation in the kingdom.
Now it's food taken at evening.
>> Different meal.
>> Yeah. The NIV says they were called to a
banquet.
>> No,
>> it's not.
>> No, because then it
>> it gets lost, right?
>> Negates the whole plan.
>> The whole plan is gone. So, you really
don't know. The Bible in basic English
says a great feast.
>> Then you might think that this is just a
repetition of what was said in Matthew.
Yeah.
>> No, it's not.
>> Other translations say a meal.
>> No.
The Luther and the Alba Fela say abent
which is correct evening meal.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So you can lose it in the various
translations. The King James is very
accurate.
>> So you can only get this really in
English properly in the King James.
>> Yeah. And then it makes all of the
difference once you realize what the
difference between the invitations are.
>> Correct. So let's go to Luke and read
this one. It's very similar.
>> Mhm. But it it's it will be similar. But
because the same invitation,
>> it's just a different time.
>> And sent his servant at supper time to
say to them that were bidden, "Come, for
all things are now ready." It's a little
bit more emphatic.
>> All things are ready.
>> Yeah. All things is ready. Now we're in.
>> And they all with one consent began to
make excuses.
>> Wow.
>> It's the same. We don't want to.
>> The f the first said unto him, I've
bought a piece of ground. I must needs
go and see to it. I pray thee have me
excused. Another said, I've bought five
yolk of oxen. Got to prove them. I've
got a new John Deere tractor.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm I just got it. I just
want
>> Man, it's stronger than five oxen. I'm
going to check this thing out. I pray
thee have me excused. And another said,
I've married a wife and therefore I
cannot come. So that servant came and
showed his lord these things. Then the
master of the house being angry said to
his servants, "Go out quickly
into the streets and lanes of the city."
What city is he talking about? Is he
talking about Jerusalem?
>> Jerusalem is gone.
>> So he's talking about antiypical
Jerusalem. M
>> go and find people in the church.
>> Yeah.
>> That will accept me as king.
>> Yeah. The invitation went out to all.
>> They went went to the Christian
churches.
>> Go and find them in the city
>> and bring in Heather the poor,
>> the maimed, the halt and the blind. Now,
these are in the city
>> of God basically in the church. Who made
them poor and maimed and blind and halt?
>> The church made them. The church made
them blind and lame and whole
>> by their traditions
>> and by their teachings and their
immortality of their soul
>> and their eternal burning hell and their
>> looking forward to
>> predestination
>> and looking forward to a kingdom on
earth
earth and complacency
>> and having destroyed everybody and their
faith in God by their
>> unbiblical tradition. s in the place of
the word of God.
>> The servants said, "Lord, it is done.
I've done it as I have commanded." But
there's still room. There weren't enough
in the church.
So, Martin, where's he going to look?
He's going to look amongst the others
that are not part of the church.
>> Yep. Same like he did the first time.
>> So, we're going to go to the Muslims.
We're going to go to
the ancestor worshippers. We're going to
go to the Shiites. We're going to go to
the atheists.
And the servant said,"Lord, it is done
as thou has commanded, and yet there's
room." So what now? Go into the
highways.
>> So now we're going outside of the
Christian church
and go into the hedges. The modern
normally a hedge is full of thorns and
if you end up in it, you get trapped.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Trapped in all kinds of doctrines. And
compel them to come in that my house be
filled. For I say unto you, that none of
these men which were bidden,
same as with the Jews,
>> those churches,
>> shall taste of my supper.
>> Yeah. If they cling to those doctrines,
>> they're not going to have it. All right.
So this invitation can we say is the
same call that went to the Jews to
accept their messiah the anointed one
the king as ruler but this time it is
directed to the Christian churches
because it's at the end of the Christian
period
>> they had claimed to accept Jesus as
their messiah their advocate and their
savior would they also welcome him as
their king
>> to set up his kingdom and to rule over
them as loyal subjects
now My next question is Martin. The
first invitation to the Jews has gone
out. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Then there was Pentecost which was a
great call to them come up.
>> They had an opportunity.
When did this invitation go out to the
churches? Was there such an invitation?
>> Definitely.
>> Are we still waiting for it or has it
come already?
>> It has come already.
>> We need to make sure.
>> Definitely.
Was it not at the end of the 2,300
evenings and mornings when the first
angel's message sounded?
>> Yes.
>> The time of his judgment has come.
Worship him who made.
>> Mhm.
>> Did they not react the same as the Jews
when the midnight cry went into the
world?
>> Yes. This is now the churches that where
this message went to.
>> Correct. Did they not spiritually treat
the heralds of that message and chase
them out of the churches? Didn't they
treat them spitefully?
Did they not fall? And was the house not
left to them desolate?
>> Yeah.
>> Doesn't the Bible say it actually became
a house of demons?
>> It's very sad.
>> So, it's the same as the house of
Israel.
>> Jesus went out from the mo from the holy
to the most holy and they was stuck.
>> Correct.
>> From the holy.
>> Did the house not become a house of
demons and every unclean and detestable
bird? Your house is left to you
desolate. Your house is left to you
desolate. We have a repeat. M
when did the message go out? 1843
444. All right. Martin the Millerite
movement.
You must imagine the times because the
great awakening was taking place.
Finey was teaching.
>> He was a millennialist.
The church is going to rule.
>> Like the Pharisees said, "Here comes
Miller." And he says, "Sorry guys, not
going to happen.
>> The king is coming. You must accept him
as your ruler.
>> But this is being told to the churches.
>> To the churches.
>> Your your king is coming.
>> He never told them change your
denomination or anything. It went to all
the churches. Went to the Baptists. It
went to the Methodists. It went to the
congregationalists. It went to all the
churches. Right. Yeah. And here they
were in their thousands in various
churches getting this invitation.
Exactly the same as happened in the time
of Jesus to the Jews. And the disciples
were preaching this. So the Millerite
movement said,
>> "Sorry guys,
it's a premillennial coming of the
king."
>> Yes.
>> And he will rule. They were teaching,
"No, it's a millennial rule and the
church will rule."
>> Yeah. It is expedient that you guys shut
up or else we lose our position.
>> Exactly. Same thing.
>> Isn't that what happened?
>> Precisely.
>> Well, let's just look at this feast of
trumpets. That's the heralding of the
judgment to come.
>> In Leviticus, we read
uh 23:23. And the Lord spake unto Moses,
saying, Speak unto the children of
Israel, saying, In the seventh month, in
the first day of the month, you shall
have a Sabbath, a memorial of blowing of
the trumpets, a holy convocation. That's
the feast of trumpets.
Ye shall do no survival work therein,
but you shall offer an offering made by
fire unto the Lord.
Okay. When was this? The first of day of
the month.
>> Yeah. Of the seventh month. the day of
atonement. Then
23:26, and the Lord spake unto Moses,
saying also on the 10th day, okay,
>> of the seventh month, so that's 10 days
later,
>> there shall be a day of atonement. It
shall be a holy convocation unto you,
and you shall afflict your souls, an
offering, an offering made by fire unto
the Lord. Now when the Millerites
preached,
did they later on understand that the
the day of atonement was the issue?
>> Yes.
>> And not the coming of Christ to cleanse
the earth.
>> No.
>> But to cleanse the sanctuary of
defilement which happened on the day of
atonement, right?
>> Yes. Yes. Moving.
>> Okay. So that was on the 10th day of the
seventh month.
and you shall do no work in that same
day, for it is a day of atonement to
make an atonement for you before the
Lord your God. For whatsoever soul it be
that shall not be afflicted in that same
day, he shall be cut off from amongst
his people. And whatsoever soul it be
that doeth any work on that same day,
the same sh soul shall I destroy from
amongst his people.
Martin, this is very interesting.
When it comes to work and destruction,
>> this is exactly the same as the robe of
righteousness.
I cannot work for my righteousness.
>> Yeah, I understand.
>> I have to accept the robe of
righteousness.
>> So the wedding invitation,
you have to have the wedding garment.
>> Yeah, you have to accept
>> correct
>> the garment.
>> There's no works that you can do to
attain it. beautiful
>> friend.
>> Why haven't you got this robe on? Right.
So in a in a veiled sense here we have
the same story.
>> It's beautiful. So God said that that's
why it's was basic like the Sabbath to
you.
>> Correct.
>> You don't work in that because you
accept what he has
>> his righteousness. So if you do any
work, you cannot work for the salvation.
The same soul will I destroy from
amongst these people. You will be thrown
out and there will be nashing of teeth.
You shall do no manner of work. It shall
be a statute forever throughout your
generations. You cannot have a salvation
by works, by rituals, by traditions, or
by whatever you want to call it.
>> It shall be unto you a Sabbath of rest,
and you shall afflict your souls. Then
the ninth day of the month of at
evening, from even unto even shall you
celebrate your Sabbath. Okay?
And then there was a feast of boos. And
the Lord spake unto Moses, saying, Speak
unto the children of Israel, saying, The
15th day of the seventh month shall be a
feast of tabernacles for seven days unto
the Lord.
>> So you had the feast of trumpet. 10 days
later, you had the atonement. 5 days
later, you had the feast of tabernacles.
Basically, you were going home.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So that's the final events.
>> And and it's for seven days,
>> correct? And the feast of trumpets was
10 days before the day of atonement
>> where you were preparing yourself for
the day of atonement.
>> Correct. That your generations may know
that I made the children of Israel to
dwell in boos when I brought them out of
the land of Egypt. I am the Lord your
God. So here is actually an event taking
place which prefigures a greater reality
later.
So Martin, the feast of trumpets preeded
the day of atonement by 10 days.
>> Mhm.
>> Correct. The Millerite movement began in
>> when the Baptist preacher William Miller
started publicly sharing his belief
based on the biblical studying
prophecies that Christ was going to come
and there was imminent around 1843 he
first said which was later modified to
1844.
>> Mhm.
>> So this message went to whom? To all the
churches.
>> Yeah. all the churches irrespective of
denomination there was no call to change
your denomination nothing the call was
Christ is coming accept him as king
>> that's it prepare
>> now this preaching only really took off
after the sign in heaven which was the
falling of the stars
>> and that was in 1833
>> and Miller said the time will be
fulfilled in 1843.
>> Yeah,
>> that's 10 years.
>> Years.
>> 10 years, right?
>> 10 years. 10 days. 10 years. It It might
be farfetched.
>> That's okay.
>> But day principle, it could just be.
Maybe not. We're not going to push the
point or belabor the point. It's just
interesting. So his preaching gained
significant traction during the second
great awakening and attracted tens of
thousands of followers leading to the
great disappointment
>> when the expected event didn't occur and
then it was modified to 1844 because
they realized that they had counted the
the zero and you can't count the zero.
It is interesting that the Millerite
movement grew slowly and then became a
mighty movement in the churches
particularly after the sign of the
falling stars in 1833.
>> So for 10 years
Miller preached
>> preach. Yeah.
And after Malah who took over the advent
movement.
>> That's it. Because then and it's
actually very important that people
realize that even this great
disappointment was prophesied.
>> Yes, it was prophesied. But it's
fascinating that the Millerite movement
ended basically in 1843.
Yeah. And then the advent movement took
over and they discovered the fault in
their reasoning.
>> Yeah.
>> He wasn't coming to cleanse the earth by
his second coming. He was coming to the
day of atonement, antiypical day of
atonement to cleanse the sanctuary.
>> So it so it moves chronologically same
as the feasts.
>> Correct. And you had to have the robe of
righteousness.
There was to be no worksbased religion.
So Miller had predicted the end of the
2,300 day prophecy
for 1843. And after this dates, the
churches finally distanced themselves
from the advent movement.
Can the day principle be part of this
coincidence? I'm I'm saying maybe.
>> Well, it's interesting.
>> It makes very good sense because we are
now currently in the antitypical day of
atonement still.
>> Correct. So the advent movement and its
believers
had to free themselves from the
doctrines of the churches. They preached
immortality.
>> Mhm.
>> They preached eternal hell. They
preached this monstrous doctrine of
arbitrary predestination.
>> Yeah.
>> They preached free grace and mercy
without justice.
>> They pre preached abrogation of the law.
the law was no more.
They preached the efficacy of the
sacraments. Even the Protestant
churches, many of them retained some of
the sacraments, two in fact,
>> whereas the Catholic Church preached
seven sacraments, a means to salvation.
There's no such thing.
Some of the Protestant churches like the
Methodists preached that they were
ordinances, but not sacraments.
>> But the Lutheran still stuck to
sacraments.
The two apartments of the sanctuary, the
correct understanding of the millennial
and postmillennial restoration, the
resurrection and translation of the
just, the punishment of the wicked. All
of these things, Martin, they had
confused.
>> All in scripture and none of it in the
creeds.
>> Just think about it for a moment. What a
mess the devil and his victims had
introduced into the churches.
irreparable systems that had to be
abandoned because they could not be
purged of their errors.
>> Yeah.
>> Babylon had reached the point of no
return. The Jews had reached the point
of no return.
The antitypical Steven had now to be
stoned.
There's no room for new wine in old
bottles. There had to be a renewing of
the mind. New wine needed new bottles.
It was necessary that the message of the
coming Messiah was to be preached to the
churches. But seeing that you rejected
it, we're going to call the people out
of Babylon.
>> That's it. They Well, actually there
they became Babylon.
>> Yes.
>> Because they were the reformation and
all these churches started.
>> So immediately after this event, you get
the second angel's message which says
>> Babylon has fallen fallen twice.
>> Yeah. Because the Catholic Church had
already fallen
>> literally.
>> But the Protestants had now also fallen.
What did they reject? The coming
millennial king.
>> Yeah, that's it.
>> They wanted to rule.
>> That's and that's why they stuck to
their creeds and their doctrines.
>> Correct. So when creeds collide with
truth, you have a pro problem, right?
>> The Protestant Reformation had freed
itself of many papal errors, but not
all. No, not only did they retain many,
but they added many of their own.
All kinds of confusions.
Romans 12:2, "And be not conformed to
this world, but be transformed by the
renewing of your mind that you may prove
what is the good and acceptable and
perfect will of God." You have to find
it in the Bible.
>> Do you find immortality of the soul in
the Bible?
>> No.
>> Exactly opposite. Do you find this
millennial rule of the church in the
Bible? No. No. You find the rule of
Christ in the Bible.
>> Do you find uh the abrogation of the law
in the Bible?
>> Jesus said, "If you love me, keep my
commandments." I don't see where he is
abregating it.
>> Exactly. And I've not come to abolish
the law.
>> No.
>> So all of these doctrines,
why are they in the creeds? Right. M
>> in 1438
>> the seven sacraments baptism,
confirmation, the eukarist, penance,
extreme uncction, orders, matrimony were
first decreed by the council of
Florence, though they had been taught
before.
>> So now it becomes a creed. None of that
is true.
>> The ordinances you cannot be saved in
Catholic thinking. If something is a
sacrament, it's a means to salvation.
Sure.
And the dragon was wroth with the woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
her seed.
So the churches had received the
message,
but they rejected it. So they threw the
people out of the churches.
>> Yeah.
>> And say, "Why would you want the Lord to
come to punish poor little sinners?
We don't want him as king.
>> We want to rule."
>> Wow. Can you imagine it?
>> And they threw them out of the churches.
This exactly what they said. You will
stop preaching in this name. You will
stop preaching that Christ is coming as
king.
So they make war against those that keep
the commandments of God. In other words,
they accept him as king.
>> Yes.
>> And have the testimony of Jesus Christ.
They accept him as Messiah and they
believe his word.
So why did the churches generally reject
the message of the premillennial coming
of Christ to set up his kingdom? Why did
they do it?
>> Was it because they had preconceived
ideas of a temporal millennium where the
church would rule the nations?
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> Isn't that what we discussed with Wilson
and uh others?
>> That's it. They want they believe this.
The Christian nationalist believes that
they will rule. Exactly. Isn't that the
same issue that led the Jews to reject
Christ and his kingdom?
>> 100%.
>> So when the Jews as a nation rejected
Christ as the king, did they not fall
and the house become desolate?
>> Yeah.
>> Would not the same apply to the
Christian churches when they did the
same?
>> 100%.
>> Is God fair?
>> Always.
>> Two wedding invitations.
>> One to the Jews in the beginning of the
ministry, one to the churches, both of
them rejected. And how much of a
fulfillment of prophecy is this? Because
they moved from being Protestants to
being a false prophet.
>> Can you see Martin?
By removing or changing one word in the
Bible, you miss all of this.
>> You miss all of it. And
>> by changing supper to a meal
>> or a feast,
>> who else can be behind that but the
enemy?
>> The enemy is behind that for sure. So
what's the consequence?
The next angel says Babylon is fallen.
We've discussed that, right? It's
fallen.
>> Yeah.
>> At great city, because she made all the
nations drink of the wine of her wroth
of her fornication. All of those false
doctrines.
>> Revelation 18:2.
And he cried mightily with a strong
voice, saying, Babylon the great is
fallen, is fallen. She's become a
habitation of devils. Your house is
desolate. What does the Bible say? If
you sweep the house and you clean it
>> and you don't fill it with the truth,
what happens?
>> Seven times, seven comes back.
>> Seven demons worse than the first.
>> All right. And so it's become a house of
every unclean spirit and unclean hateful
birth where they preach salvation
without law. where they preach the Holy
Spirit will fill you and that will be
your sign.
>> Yeah.
>> Etc. etc. etc.
>> Even actually making themselves gods.
>> Correct. Going that far.
So Martin the second angel's message
separated the people that would go
forward with the truth till the end of
time. So where are they preaching?
They're preaching inside the city
>> like the Jews and they're in the
highways and the hedges.
>> Yeah. Everywhere. They're standing on
the wall.
>> They're preaching to everyone. And let's
ask the question,
>> is God concerned about everyone? Didn't
he die for everyone?
>> For everyone. So if you were born into a
voodoo culture,
>> wouldn't God have compassion and try to
pull you out of that culture?
>> Always. If you were born into another
religion, whether it be Shintoism or
Islam or whatever,
>> and there's no salvation in terms of the
Messiah that can give you the robe of
righteousness,
>> uh wouldn't God have compassion?
>> Yeah.
>> Isn't he sending dreams and visions to
these people
>> in droves? So many a message that we
must bring to them.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. So after this message went to the
churches, it still goes to the to the
city to the Christian churches.
>> Those churches, those Protestant
churches that became the false prophet.
Now it's not that the message is not
going still to them as well.
>> Yes, they can still accept it. Just like
the Jews could be grafted in, so they
can be grafted in. But the message is
also going to the highways and the
hedges. Well, can we just say, don't we
see that sometimes whole churches
accepting the truth, correct? Walking
over.
>> Absolutely.
So, the first call to the supper went to
the churches. They rejected it.
>> So, a second call goes out unto any that
will hear.
>> Yeah.
>> It was necessary that it first go to the
churches.
>> Mhm.
>> Namely, the maimed, the halt, the blind.
That's like me. Like you. That's it. So
the servant came and showed his lord
these things. Then the master of the
house being angry said to his servant,
"Go out quickly into the streets and
lanes of the city within the church.
bringing in the poor, spiritually poor,
the maimed, those that had been hurt by
the church's teachings,
>> and the halt,
those that are lost their strength,
>> and the blind, spiritually blind.
>> So the question again to rub it in, who
made them spiritually blind? the
teachings, the the leaders.
>> Didn't the Pharisees make the people at
their time spiritually blind?
>> The leaders because they want to cling
to the leadership.
>> Did Jesus call them blind?
>> Yes.
>> Let the blind lead the blind. They will
both fall into a ditch. Right. Who made
them?
>> Who rendered them nonfunctional?
Who made them halt and limp and
crippled? It was the churches. M
>> so the city the churches are here called
a city
>> Babylon.
>> Yeah.
>> Under the loud cry his people were
called out of Babylon that had become a
house of demons. Pentecost called his
people out of a fallen desolate Jewish
dispensation
and thousands came out and became
Christians followers of Christ. Same
under the second Pentecost.
Thousands will sever their ties with
Babylon and become Seventh Day
Adventists.
Not I'm not talking about denominational
now. I'm talking about seventh day
believers in the coming of Christ as
king
which happens to also be a denomination.
>> That's it. There's only one way to
qualify for this because that also that
Seventh Day Adventists the other name is
called the remnant. Correct.
>> And there's a qualification to be part
of that. Keeping the commandments and
having the faith of Jesus
>> and the testimony of Jesus, which is the
spirit of prophecy. It's all very clear
in the scriptures.
>> So, Sardis,
>> which in the seven churches represents
Protestantism,
would not accept the doctrine of the
second coming. Therefore, the coming of
the Lord will be to them like a thief in
the night.
>> Yep. and it will become catch them
unawares and with an overwhelming
surprise
>> but you're not supposed to be unaware of
it. All right. So, Revelation 3:3
remember therefore how they hast
received and heard talking to Sardis,
>> hold fast, repent,
>> Mhm.
>> If therefore you shall not watch
>> for what? for the signs of the coming of
Christ to become the king, the ruler of
the universe.
>> I will come unto thee as a thief and
thou shalt not know what hour I will
come upon thee. That's why they're
preaching their temporal millennium. How
they're going to preach for a thousand
years. I've got news for them. Nothing
none of that's going to happen.
If I may ask a question, if this was
referring to them not knowing the hour,
does that mean that maybe the others
that are watching might be a little bit
more awake of the hour which
>> Oh, the Bible says so. Let's read it.
One Thessalonians, but of the times and
seasons, brethrens, you have no need
that I write to you. For yourselves know
perfectly that the day of the Lord comes
as a thief in the night. To whom?
>> To whom?
>> To Sardis.
>> Exactly. Those are not waiting. For when
they shall say peace and safety, then
sudden destruction cometh upon them as a
travail upon a woman with child, and
they shall not escape. But ye, brethren,
you're not in darkness that the day
should overtake you as a thief. So
Martin, we know from the scripture that
Christ is going to come and set up his
kingdom.
>> And he even said, look at the signs.
Watch ye therefore and pray.
>> Correct. You are all children of the
light and the children of the day. We
are not night nor darkness. Therefore,
let us not be asleep as do others,
>> but let us watch and be sober. Men, we
can know what time
the second wedding advoc invitation has
come and gone.
>> Yes.
>> The preaching that Babylon has fallen
has it come and gone. Mhm.
>> The preaching accept God's law and do
not accept the tradition, the mark of
the beast, the false Sabbath because the
Sabbath stands for rest. The Sabbath
therefore stands for accepting the robe
of righteousness
>> and the authority of the king
>> and the authority of the king. That's
it.
>> It's as simple as that.
So those that cry peace and safety like
the churches, they will not discern the
hour.
>> Yeah.
>> They will be praying and swinging their
hands and speaking in tongues and
believing that they will soon rule.
>> Yeah.
>> And what agreement has the temple of God
with idols? For ye are the temple of the
living God, as God has said, I will
dwell in them and walk in them, and I
will be their God, and they shall be my
people. Wherefore, what does it say?
>> Come out.
>> Come out of them.
>> Be separate.
Did the Christians heed the call to come
out? And did they leave Jerusalem and go
to Pella?
>> Yes. Not one perished.
>> Therefore, come out of Babylon.
>> Come out.
>> Touch not the unclean thing, and I will
receive you, and I will be a father unto
you, and you shall be my sons and
daughters, says the Lord. So the halt,
the maim, the blind left the churches
and the philosophies they were involved
in. How many people are sitting in
church saying
there's something not quite right here?
>> Exactly. How many?
Because of the shameful treatment they
received when they confronted them with
the truth. When you go to the pastor and
you say to him, "Excuse me, but doesn't
it say we must keep the seventh day and
isn't that Saturday? They said, "No, no,
no, no, no, no. Don't worry about that."
>> Exactly.
>> And what about the premillennium of
Christ? No, no, no. Relax. We're going
to rule. Don't worry.
>> So, Martin, the truth will set you free.
To the Jews who had believed him, Jesus
said, "If you hold to my teachings, you
are really my disciples."
Could we say there, "If you switch to
creeds, you're going to be in trouble."
>> Yes.
John 8:32 then you will know the truth
because my word is truth
>> and the truth will set you free.
First wedding uh invitation
>> gone
>> done and dusted. Second invitation done
and dusted. Fall of Babylon done and
dusted.
>> Preaching the end of the day of
atonement
virtually done and dust basically on the
edge. Next thing,
>> seven days going home.
>> Seven seventh day of tabernacle feast.
Going home.
>> Oh, we're going to go home. And
everybody in that seven days at least
keep the Sabbath once.
>> Yes. So, you can actually with
confidence say that nobody will enter
heaven without having kept at least one
Sabbath.
>> Correct. Let's pray.
>> Amen.
>> Heavenly Father,
thank you for the wedding invitation.
And I pray Lord that our oxen and our
entanglements with the world won't keep
us from accepting that invitation.
This invitation has gone to all the
churches. Most of them have rejected or
virtually all of them. And so I pray
that uh the halt, the blind, the lame
will come and accept this invitation so
that we can have a feast of tabernacles
together. is my prayer in Jesus' name.
Amen.
>> Amen.
Heat.